Dopustite da vam dam novosti.
Hm,
vidio sam one TikTok Shop videozapise u kojima su ljudi poput,
oh,
ja to radim zbog ovoga i bla,
bla, bla.
Uvijek dobiva puno pogleda.
I bio sam kao, wow,
pitam se koliko prodaje dolazi od onih videozapisa koji dobivaju puno pregleda?
Ne puno.
Mislim da sam zaradio poput 33 dolara u provizijama iz TikTok trgovine.
Um,
što je divlje jer je video na kraju dobio milijun pregleda.
Dakle. Ali ljubav.
Zapravo sam se stvarno bojala pogledati u komentare.
Nisam bio siguran hoće li ljudi biti poput,
o moj Bože, začepi,
bla, bla, bla.
Ali zaboravio sam.
Ovo je TikTok gdje su ljudi povezani onako kako se sviđamo.
Dakle,
komentari smo ispunjeni ljubavlju i podrškom.
Htio sam se vratiti i obavijestiti vas.
Nisam htio samo nestati.
Uistinu sam u skrbničkoj borbi.
Kao da se svaki tjedan sastajem s forenzičkim psihologom,
tako da sam pomalo nervozan.
Kao,
o moj Bože,
ovaj momak može,
kao,
on zna sve o meni.
Prije nego što pričam.
Osjećam se kao,
u svakom slučaju.
Dakle,
um,
zapravo imam dragog prijatelja na Instagramu.
Dakle,
ako TikTok ode,
ja sam vrlo aktivan na.
Ja sam zapravo malo aktivniji na Instagramu,
nekako.
Ja sam na YouTubeu.
I primijetio sam da me gomila ljudi počinje pratiti na YouTubeu,
tako da to cijenim.
Imam sadržaj koji ću uskoro prenijeti na YouTube,
pa vam hvala.
Hm,
i ja ću se više usredotočiti na to.
Samo trebam ovo skrbničko sranje da mi se makne s puta.
Ali um imam vrlo,
vrlo dragog prijatelja koji je um bio
velikodušan sa mnom u prošlosti za pravne stvari.
Bila je kao, hej,
djevojka,
shvatila sam te.
Dakle,
većina ljudi na mom Instagramu,
poput mojih Instagram priča.
Pomogli su mi i pomogli.
Hm,
a onda je moj prijatelj rekao,
u redu, gdje si?
Dopustite mi da pokrijem ostalo.
Za sada ostajem u jebenoj borbi.
I osjećam se stvarno voljeno i podržano i ne sam,
jer puno puta ne volim dijeliti borbu.
Osjećam se kao da sam postao taj glas poput,
ostavi svog muža,
možeš to učiniti,
možeš to uspjeti.
Osjećam se kao da ako podijelim borbu kroz koju prolazim u poteškoćama,
to bi moglo obeshrabriti neke žene da odu.
Možda su kao, vidi,
znao sam da je to zastrašujuće i ne želim otići.
Ona se bori.
Hm,
i pretpostavljam da samo moram biti otvoreniji i iskreniji,
kao da postoji borba i još uvijek sam sretan.
To je baš kao svako malo i onda postoje neki vapaji ili postoje neki suze,
ali sve između je ispunjeno srećom i kao dobrota života.
Hm,
ali i ja jednostavno ne volim razgovarati o svojim
legalnim sranjima jer ne želim da moj TikTok sudjeluje u tome.
Kao da želim sve odvojiti.
Dakle,
samo sam želio svima dati novosti.
Milijun ljudi gleda video i komentira.
Hm,
To je malo neodoljivo,
ali dobro mi ide.
Još uvijek sam u borbi i ljubav i ohrabrenje su ono što me održava.
Puno vam hvala.